ah
that's some good water hey
folks
uh hope everybody is
doing well you know uh
grading on the curve
of current events
uh i remember
when we were several months into covet
and it was becoming clear that it wasn't
going to wrap up
quickly
um
i remember that you know when people ask
me how
uh i am i would say that you know
scaling for covid i'm fine
and i feel like i'm there again not just
because covet hasn't gone away but
because now it's you know scaling for
america
i'm fine
i don't live in america so i'm better
than most
i mean well depending on where you do
live there's plenty of other
going on
yeah
but uh
it's good to see everybody i'm gonna
actually
make sure that the shirt gets a proper
look in so give me a second here
so
this
i
feel is uh important
because that
is
more than ever
my current mood
so
uh hijo silverworks.com
if you enjoy the design
they make amazing stuff and they are
coming out with new designs soon which
is wonderful
so uh reminder at the start um
if you're new here
i do try and keep up with the chat i do
not guarantee
that i will see a comment the only thing
that will guarantee it
will be to do it as a super chat in
which case i will guarantee to read and
respond to your comment or question
you'll also get a heart from me and
appreciation uh the other way is that if
you are a patreon supporter on the
council of geeks discord there is a
channel devoted to asking questions um
on here i am going to add an additional
thing though because last time
people kept adding more questions as i
was trying to get through them
once i make the switch over
to the discord to look at those comments
that's the cutoff so
any new things written
um
at the after i start going over those
i i'm not going to take them in so if
you have questions to put in the discord
server
do so
now or over the next half hour or 40
minutes or so because once i'm over
there i'm not going to take in new
questions because it it kind of dragged
on for more than it was intended to
uh
up here in canada i cover our government
keeps budgeting and
policying
to the assumption that we saved tons
staying home
all right
nice chest and yeah mood yeah i was kind
of showing off the
rack a little bit a little bit
went to a pride production of rocky or
on saturday oh that does sound nice have
i seen contra point's latest tweets
today
funny yet frightening i actually don't
follow contra points on twitter
um there are a number of creators who i
enjoy their work but i don't follow on
twitter just because
i i do my best to curate my twitter feed
fairly narrowly
um so no i haven't
it's sad that guns have more rights than
us oh guns have far more rights
and then they're
they are having any restrictions on
their rights
steadily stripped away while our actual
rights are being stripped away yeah
this um
i don't want this to be a downer of a uh
of a stream but like
it's gonna come up i know that
ah
i know you said cops don't belong at
prides how do you feel in light of the
proud boys incident i'm assuming black
cover you mean the thing in idaho i
don't think that was actually the proud
boys i think that was a different group
and actually um
i'm not uh
i'm not mad that you asked because a
number of people did
and the short version is that actually
does not alter my opinion at all
so for people who don't know
um
in idaho there were i think
31 i think it was 31. members of an
extremist uh patriot front thank you b
parker uh of an extremist far-right
group um who were all packed into a
u-haul and they were on their way to
pride
basically to
cause havoc and chaos at a pride event
and they were arrested before they got
there now prior to that happening i have
put out a short video
uh stating my assertion that i do not
believe
on-duty cops have any place
at pride events um you know with the
understanding that with certain types of
events like parades sometimes the police
have to be involved to cordon off
streets or whatever
that accepted
um and initially i pushed back people
saying well what about security well
first of all for events like pride
the event organizers are empowered to
run their own security you know that's
why you have bouncers at clubs instead
of cops
but
a lot of people asked after that
um
thing happened where patriot front got
arrested before they got to a pride
event and
some people asked me kind of in the way
you did um which was to say does this
change your opinion other people tried
to use it as a gotcha on me like oh i
bet you'd bet you are happy for the cops
now here's the thing and here's why it
does not alter my opinion
they were not stopped
by by the presence of police at pride
they were stopped and detained
because the police responded to a call
they got about suspicious activity which
is what's supposed to happen that's
their job and investigating suspicious
activity they arrested these people they
arrested them before they arrived at
pride
so the first thing that i have to
have to stress
these people were not stopped
because there was an act of police
presence at pride
they weren't that's not why they were
stopped
and i
still hold not in my belief that not
only is there
um
no place for active on duty cops just
patrolling a pride event because
whatever potential and it is potentially
theoretical i'll come back to that in a
second whatever potential or theoretical
benefit that their presence would lend
if a crisis were to happen in real time
that is a hypothetical benefit
whereas the
immediate impact of their presence
being the intimidation factor of having
an arm of the state present at what is
still and even more so now that has been
in a while a protest event
no i'm not okay with that
and i'll also reassert and i feel very
comfortable saying this especially the
more that we find out about what did or
did not happen at the uvalde school
shooting
i am not confident
that
if something were to actually happen if
say the patriot front did
get to the pride event and enact their
plan to
mess people up
i honestly do not believe that the
presence of beliefs would have helped
the situation
i think at best it would have added to
the chaos and potentially could have
made things much much worse
so
no uh
that did nothing to change my opinion
uh i think the proud boys incident was
that a proud boy entered a library
waving and gun while drag queens were
reading books to kids
ah yes no that does not change my
opinion either
because
if your solution to
[Music]
[ __ ] with guns showing up at a
children's event
is to post people with guns at the same
event
no your entire approach your solution is
working backwards which is the
fundamental problem with how we approach
gun quote-unquote safety in this country
in the first and place
anyways i did get um
membership renewal from michael anderson
doyle seven months of love and geekdom
and fun in seven days i get my uh wpath
letter and the day after that hrt i am
very happy for you i really am dharma
welcome back hope you enjoyed your break
i did i mean friday wasn't fun but you
know seems like uh we all get ready to
go on vacation and relax and then the
world has other plans i mean the world
the world's gonna fall apart kind of
regardless of what we do so that's sort
of um
i'm at a point like you have to try and
have fun you have to hold on to your joy
cause like
a lot of the horrible stuff that's going
on is going on regardless of whether we
are miserable or finding joy and
i'm going to find as much joy as i can
there i mean i was planning to do it
anyway but i'll tell you going to a rent
fair this past weekend was extra
cathartic
being able to pretend i lived in a
different time and environment than the
one i actually live in
plus you know firing the longbows
felt really good
i like winning the archery contest
i'll just be upfront about that
and some better news uh i got my video
essay on amy's choice finally out oh
very nice i cited one of your videos on
worst comic tropes yes
somehow i made a link there thank you
i'll try and check that out at some
point uh vacuum of
comments uh
there's gonna be a kurt cobain biopic
what are your thoughts i don't like
biopics as a genre so
neutral to
please don't
hey kind of take your pick
very your live stream tired who gives me
so tell me
what's become of my ship
yep
uh john vinyls thank you very much for
the super chat i did not expect vera to
get philosophical in this session i mean
i've got a stein of water
and
i've been
mulling over a lot of
nonsense
so yeah
yeah it was it was probably gonna happen
what's the story behind your thumbnail
today i'm
i'm queer and pissed
it's it's pretty straightforward also
i'm six months on hrt congratulations
jamie that's wonderful
i like your earrings i actually bought
these at the um
at the ren fair
um
from from one of the
from one of the the uh stalls that uh
there's some of them there's some of the
vendors you're like
you people
so like in one of them uh amongst other
leather works available this wasn't the
same one i bought this from but among
other leatherworks available there were
very lovely floggers
like they
they were real pretty they were too
expensive they were too rich for my
blood but they were real pretty and then
the uh the stall where i got these um
which also have a rune on them which i
like
um
[Music]
and the they had
these various harnesses
you know buckles and leather
and uh especially i saw one like on a on
sort of a mannequin bust as a display
i'm like that's
that's just a kink harness
they're just selling it
uh but you know there's so many leather
straps and buckles that you see at a
rent fair like i get how they they kind
of
snuck it under the radar but i spot that
i'm like hmm you don't normally sell
that to rent fair crowd or at least not
normally for rent fair purposes
biopics can be good look at rock and of
course they can be good
but i don't like the genre like i can
find examples of good movies in
virtually any genre but that doesn't
mean that i like the genre any better
uh sorry give me a second
hi vera i just wanted to say that you've
really helped me feeling comfortable
with being gender fluid as there was a
lot of stigma behind it as i'm only 16
and people act like it's not real
uh amelie i
the
the thing that i can tell you is
especially at the age of 16
the the main thing that you
lack
um
versus
someone of my age
is
an ability to fully
properly curate your surroundings
and that can make things really
difficult if you are in
a place in a situation
where you feel
unaccepted
or ridiculed
or
um
just where you don't fit
at the age you're at your ability to
extricate yourself from that
is um
is very limited
sorry hang on one second
all right that's fine
um
but
one of the benefits like there's a lot
that sucks about being an adult i'm not
gonna pretend otherwise
however
one of the good things is it enhances
your ability to be able to curate your
surroundings and determine
the kind of people
that are going to have access to you
there's still going to be some things
you can't help you can't always help
what kind of co-workers you get
but you can decide who you spend your
time with you can decide who has access
to your time
as opposed to just being
you have to deal with this friend pool
that's at school you know you live with
your parents
the freedom to curate
your chosen
family is gonna do a lot
to cut down
on things like people claiming that your
identity is made up
and
the thing that i always think
when people
make claims like that when they say
something like gender fluid doesn't
exist
my question is always
okay
assume you're right
what's the harm
and
the [ __ ] will go well i'm not going
to enable your delusion
and my answer to that is still going to
be what is the harm
unless you think me a dangerous person
what harm does it do
to allow me my identity
that does nothing but enhance my sense
of self
and has no negative impact on anyone
else around me
and some people will have very
twisted conspiratorial reasons why they
think it's still wrong some people will
just be dicks
but
the simple thing is even if it's made up
so what
i mean it's not to be very clear being
gender fluid is not invented it's not
made up
but even if it is so what what do you
care
the the people who say that it's not
real so
what
what difference does that make to
you you let people have
the things that make them
feel better about their own existence
why would you want to take that from
somebody
and the thing is i know there are lots
of people out there who actively want to
take
joy and happiness away from people and i
don't understand and i never will
i will never understand
what is gained
by attempting to strip someone
of the things that impact nobody but
themselves and that make them happy
i don't understand that as an impulse
i don't want to jinx it but are you
particularly surprised it looks like
we're gonna get out of pride month uh
uh without a parade being shot up um no
i actually did not think that would
happen
i know lots of people were very afraid
but the thing is
the thing about
mass shooters
is they go to crowded places
it's very rare that they go to
legitimately packed places
they go to places where lots of people
already are
you know that's why they target schools
workplaces
churches sometimes but the number of
people at a pride event
and especially the number of people who
frankly would have been on edge and
looking for your hostile ass
at a pride event
i actually wasn't expecting something
like that to happen i'm not gonna say i
had no fear of it i had a little
but i didn't think it would
and fingers crossed last few days it
won't
ah let's see here i enjoyed your review
of stranger things thank you vanessa it
hasn't gotten as much pushback as i was
afraid it was going to get it's gotten a
little though
uh dominick noble once pointed out that
amazon sold the leather harness he
bought for cosplay as both cosplay and
kinkwear the cakeware was cheaper it was
the same harness yeah amazon's such a
freaking scam
uh i don't know if you're the right
person to ask a member of my immediate
family is anti-abortion i'm pro-choice
is trying to change their mind being
disrespectful to them in their opinion
um
i think uh in a lot of ways jamie it's
going to depend
on why they hold that opinion
because while
um
i i wish that nobody held the opinion
that
um
the life of something that cannot live
outside of the womb is more important
than the life of a living breathing
human being
some people do have that conclusion and
different people arrive at that in
different ways
some people come at it from
a religious perspective
um
which that's probably the one where
you're going to
there's going to be the least
um
good that can come out of trying to
break them from that because if their
anti-abortion stance
is a function of their religious beliefs
then attacking that stance to them is
going to feel like attacking their
entire belief system and that's
not a conversation that's going to go
well for anybody
however there are
other people who make other arguments
and depending on what their argument is
and what their position is
there may be ways to
um be able to talk to them about it
that is respectful as i said the
religious justification for being
anti-abortion is probably the biggest
thing to just not bother
and that's not to say that like there's
no way to persuade such people but if
don't bring logic to a religion
fight if that makes sense
there was a phrase that uh went around
um
[Music]
leftist spaces a few years ago it's
still helpful to remember you can't
logic someone out of a position they
didn't logic themselves into
um and that's usually used in terms of
people who hold a position for emotional
reasons which can also happen with with
abortion but especially with something
religious if the basis for somebody for
somebody's actions is a religious belief
no argument made by someone outside of
that religious belief that doesn't take
their faith into account is ever going
to be
helpful
that having been said
if it is a religious basis
i think the thing that might be worth
doing
is that
pushing back on the idea of well if
you're so pro-life and you think all
life is precious are you pushing for
these other things this is actually
something that
um
it's gonna feel weird to say i want to
give a little bit of props to the
catholic church not a ton they are
anti-abortion however
the vatican put out a really interesting
statement in regards to what's going on
in america right now
because the catholic church is
anti-abortion
however they're also looking at a lot of
other stuff going on in america and
going this is not pro-life
you can't claim to be pro-life while
doing nothing to reign in guns you can't
claim to be pro-life while having no
safety net for children once they are
born you can't claim to be pro-life
and be
trying to expel or prevent immigrants
from
from arriving in your country because
they're not safe in their home
countries
so
i think
if someone has a religious objection to
abortion
maybe your energy is better spent
pushing back on going okay if you're
pro-life is it just fetus or are you
actually going to fight for any of this
other stuff that's really messed up
so maybe rather than trying to
break them out of the abortion position
you can redirect
again depending on where it's coming
from you can redirect that same energy
into
better use
you know the energy that they're putting
into
wanting abortion to end like
okay well you got what you wanted there
how about next you start on the
guarantee of
um family leave
how about that how about we start
working on the gun thing you know
it would be
i don't it's not going to happen but it
would be a very pleasant surprise
if
um
right to life people
would actually expand that out
to any point past when the child is born
and as a collective as a political body
they won't
on an individual one-on-one basis
maybe some of them will
let's see where i am here
uh
which doctor who episode got you the
most backlash i assume you mean review
um
probably village of the angels
i really thought that thing fell apart
hard
really hard and everybody else loved it
and people came at me
hard for not
uh thinking that that episode was very
good or not thinking that it stayed good
at least and thinking that it it's good
ideas came to nothing even within the
episode itself
i got a lot of crap for that
at least at the time
here i've officially moved into my new
house which was an absolute nightmare
moving often is uh
so i'm glad you you got through it at
least
my father used to say in his southern
accent do i smell the smell of hypocrisy
there was a tick tock that i saw i i
actually saved this i showed it to uh to
my partner liz i'm just gonna cop right
now this this stream is gonna run longer
than usual i'm just looking at i'm
looking at the time i'm looking at the
pace i'm going through this we're going
to run longer than usual i'm just owning
that at this point
but um
short version of this tick tock this guy
talks about going to a tractor pull
uh and there was this guy who was there
uh you know effeminate in this pink
cowboy hat and pink get up and there was
this uh this other couple of guys behind
him and one of them looks at the guy and
all the pain and goes ugh
why would you go to a tractor pool
dressed like that and the guy who was
with him
goes
being able to dress like that is his
god-given right what the [ __ ] do you
think freedom means earl
you know
apologies for anyone who doesn't care
for the term
but i deeply love liberal rednecks
they are the best
they are the best
uh
did i see the trailer for hocus pocus 2
i did
i don't care but um but i did yes
uh
let's see here
oh uh supreme omega
thank you very much for the super chat
uh on the mcu ms marble is six episodes
really enough time to properly adapt the
comics 113 episodes or even the classic
22 in episode format have been more
ideal
i'll have a more fully formed opinion on
that uh when it finishes
however
i am already planning a video on how the
interconnectedness of the mcu is
beginning to harm the storytelling
and i and the uh the short episode
lengths i do feel is related to that
because they're not
treating these as shows or even really
fully self-contained stories they are
treating them
as supplements to the movies and
it's hurting them so
stick a pin in that come back to it
later in the month well later next month
i say later in the month month's almost
over
ah
let's see
try and catch up again
question about harley quinn i stopped
halfway through season two episode eight
um how do they handle the whole kite man
situation did they eff it up or did they
stick the landing don't care about
spoilers i thought they handled that
pretty well
um because
so without getting into
super amounts of detail um basically
the the issue it was ivy's issue
because ivy did lot like him and cared
about him but obviously was being pulled
towards harley
but it's not like she didn't like him
but eventually he hit a point where he
just kind of went
all right this is clearly not working
and i know you say you care about me and
it's not that i don't believe you but
this
is
especially in the specific situation
where things went uh in the direction
he's just kind of like i
i can't
i can't this has gotten out of control
um which i think was a decent way to
handle it
i hear he's getting a
spin-off potentially
uh did i see lightyear no
i have no interest in seeing lightyear
i just don't think it was a good idea
for a movie
i i don't understand why they thought
that was a good idea
uh and i'm sure it's fine but i don't
care
jon vinyls thank you once again ever
been to connecticut by the way
um by and large i have been through
connecticut that is my standard
relationship with connecticut um because
i used to live in new york and
my family was still in vermont
um and this was back when i was with my
kid's mother and her family was in new
hampshire so we would regularly go
through connecticut
um
not really a place that i stopped
uh
connecticut drivers drove me up the wall
though i can tell you that i know
everyone [ __ ] about massachusetts
drivers and they are a handful
but connecticut
you folks don't know how to frickin
merge
every time every point in the highway
where lanes merged it would
just stop
dead and not because there was an
accident or even that much excessive
traffic just because you don't know how
to freaking merge in that
state ah
what is it what did i think of kenobi
god mode when he started to throw rocks
and beat vader i was fine with it
i thought it was fine i mean i could
actually see that part because
lightsabers were fired up as opposed to
hold chunks of that episode that i
couldn't see
excuse me
on the other end of the position uh are
there any doctor who episodes you really
love that everyone else completely
trashes
um
i think
the one that i
really love that i'm not gonna say
people trash it but the people who don't
like it really don't like it is can you
hear me
i like can you hear me a lot like a lot
a lot i love that episode um
a lot of people were kind of middling on
it and some people really hated it um
but i like that one a lot
uh the man who fell to earth's sequel
series came and went it seems oh that
was a thing okay i'm mainly intrigued to
see it because of bill nye taking over
bowie's role huh well that's interesting
cassie at least
uh
thank you supreme omega much appreciated
i know you're understandably sick of
high school drama so how about stories
of college life for the drama of 20
somethings are you also tired of that
um
slightly less only because they tend to
be less cliche riddled than the high
school stuff tends to be that's the
thing like one of the other aspects
that makes me really sick of high school
stories is they are deeply mired in
tropes and cliche and there are tropes
and cliches of college life and 20
something but they're not as ingrained
and as ground into the freaking dirt so
that helps
i don't know if you agree by the way but
my biggest problem with the timeless
child is that it feels like bad fan
fiction the doctor being the child felt
like the safest option kinda i
here's the thing i don't really get on
board
with a criticism that says it sounds
like fan fiction i'm not gonna say like
that i've never used it myself because i
probably have but
the thing is
that usually has more to do with
execution than concept
i mean the the idea that leia's luke's
sister that sounds fanfictiony that
sounds like the exact kind of thing a
fan fiction writer would have done to go
oh she's got better chemistry with ham
but what about luca i don't want to
break luke's heart oh we'll just make
them siblings and then we'll never bring
up the fact that they kiss before ever
again like that feels like fan fiction
but i think that has a lot more to do
with execution
than concepts
i will say
the thing to me
this isn't doctor who the thing that to
me felt like fan fiction was um
rise of skywalker
that one felt like fan fiction
very specifically in the way it did the
same crap that had already been done
just
more
and
there's a whole fleet of star destroyers
and they all have death star guns
and
then every
every single ship every single non um
first order ship in the entire galaxy
shows up and then palpatine forced
lightning's the fleet and then ray beats
palpatine because she has two
lightsabers like that
the it's that one upsmanship that felt
like fan fiction
just started dead-end paranormal park on
netflix
is it on you and your kiddos radar by
chance i'm loving it so much rep i have
never heard of that one remy
um so i can't say it is i i do know that
um
um
owl house uh last episodes of valhalla
season two are finally gonna be on
disney plus tomorrow so uh that'll be
the priority for the kid first off
um
feel free to disagree with me but as
someone who has been in that situation
and has said
uh what the doctor said i feel the
ending of
can you hear me is massively overhated
yeah when people hate on that they tend
to get very down on the doctor's
response to graham
and it's very strange to me that people
read it as her not caring or read it as
a joke
because
i didn't i
even on a re-watch i didn't i don't
understand that reading like and i don't
want to presume this across the board
but that feels like the kind of reading
that people who wanted a reason to hate
it would have
because like this doctor in particular
is
fairly neurodivergent coated
and her social awkwardness has been made
flat out explicit and brought and had
attention brought to it repeatedly
so
that to me felt like a very vulnerable
moment
where she admits that she doesn't know
what to say to him
rather just letting the moment hang
she's like look
i don't know what to say here's what i'm
going to do
because i have to do something and i
know it's not going to help and i'll
think of something to say later that
never struck me as dismissive that to me
felt vulnerable that was her admitting
she's not equipped to handle what he
just laid down in front of her
so
what's the show i want a revival season
from
i can't think of any other time i had
i'm not a big fan
of reviving old shows by and large
like i'd rather see new things for the
most part
uh regarding the mcu specifically moon
night after the show ended i went to see
how
uh they adapted moon knight i'll say as
holy hell did they water him down
[Laughter]
uh yeah moon night moon night is
moon night something i'll tell you that
uh what are you hoping for in jody's
last episode what are you dreading
they'll do
i'm still dreading
that um
[Music]
what's his face and
who's her name from flux uh are gonna be
revealed to be the doctor's parents i'm
still afraid of that
um what am i hoping for
to not hate it
that's
that's kind of it doctor versus rick
sanchez who wins i don't watch rick and
morty because i cannot stand the
characters i do not want to spend time
with them so i have no opinion
uh
i'm just imagining obi-wan's force go
screaming in horror at the kiss scene in
empire
oh that's good i like that
what's worse star wars prequel trilogy
rise of skywalker star chaser
rise of skywalker because
that capped off a
good film followed by a film i didn't
like but at least was trying to do
interesting stuff and it capped it off
with just nonsense starchaser you can
get drunk and enjoy and i've softened on
the star wars prequels being terrible i
still don't like them but like yeah
whatever
ridiculous question but i'm curious
back when you reviewed timeless child
you noticed you saw a leak related to it
from weeks before
uh this caused any sort of trauma for
many new leaks uh no i i avoid leaks for
this exact
flipping reason
uh
oh my god looking forward to your take
uh on the collector in the owl house
well we'll see
uh sarvis the drow
thank you very much for the super chat i
think my episode of doctor who that i
like way more than anyone else is power
of three the one with the cubes i really
like that one that episode like the
ending is weird
like in a way and just a
that's how you're ending it kind of way
but
up until towards the very end it's
really good
the character work in that is really
good the setup is great the way it
builds attention just seeing the
doctor's frustration and having to just
go through time linearly
linear linearly linearly
la uh that's great i love that
have i ever liked something out of spite
for example i'm so tired of being
bombarded by constant last jedi hate
it's fine if you don't like it that i
kind of like it now um
i don't think so
maybe i don't think so though
um i know i've definitely disliked
things out of spite
which isn't necessarily healthy but
uh have you listened to jaco and
lightfoot or anything with uh
the scorches i have not yeah i do have i
do have a collection of jaego and
lightfoot but i have not um
i haven't gotten to that yet
one of these days finally done with
amphibia i can check that off my list
yes yeah i need to uh i need to shoot
that review i've seen the rest of it too
i'll get to the discord
calm yourself
um
do you genuinely think hellbent is the
worst episode of modern who or does the
spot get taken by the idiot's land no
the indian slanted is worse because the
idiots lantern is harmful
hellbent is
baffling
from a
narrative standpoint hell bents worse
but
from an overall package
when you take into account the messages
that are contained within it
uh idiots lantern i have a hard time
believing i'll ever think an episode of
doctor who is worse than the idiot's
lantern
i have started watching season three of
umbrella academy i've got i think
three episodes left
to go and yes uh victor was well handled
how was my break it was great up until
the very end there uh you know because
friday was blue
[Music]
to quote godzilla mondazza's video on
moon night they played it too safe and
didn't take any risks which is why i
love doom patrol on a lot of dc stuff
they do take risks and don't apologize i
i have started doom patrol um
i i need to get back to that at some
point but yes that i'm enjoying that a
lot
uh the ending of power three was a last
minute rewrite caused by the actor who
was playing the villain giving an
unusable performance i've heard that i
haven't dug into the specifics on that
but yeah i've heard that
rumor has a russell t davies will be
taking a one division-like approach to
the 60th special hence the recasting of
rose what are your thoughts um
if they do take that approach
okay first of all
unless i miss something from the bbc
that's not a recast of
rose
so far as i'm aware
i know a lot of people assumed it was i
don't
i don't know
i don't have thoughts on that it depends
on what they do with it i'll have a
thought when i see
it do you think jimdo's best doctor who
and best torchwood scripts um
i can't remember all of his torchwood
episodes off on my head i know
countryside was pretty good
uh the tail end of the stuff he did
um
did
if he wrote the first episode of series
two which i think he might have
if he did that was really good i can't
remember if he did or not though
um as for doctor who uh
honestly
probably dinosaurs on a spaceship
did i ever see jupiter ascending uh no i
have not seen that one
i thought you weren't gonna do a review
of amphibia i wasn't gonna do a review
of season two but now that i've seen the
whole thing i'll do a fi i'll do a final
thoughts i just remember i just remember
if anyone thinks star wars last jedi was
bad just remember that in 1978 uh they
had the star wars holiday special if you
haven't seen account your blessings i've
seen it
what is my biggest hope for rtd's doctor
who run and the centenary was my biggest
fear i
my biggest fear is that he'll just slip
back into doing what he did back in
2005. um i don't think he'll do that but
that's my biggest fear my biggest hope i
don't i don't project a lot of hope
beyond just hoping i like it i want to
see what they're going to do i try not
to come up with too many specific
expectations
uh do you think doctor who is going to
dictate an episode to the events of this
past week possibly a person
with the initial r versus w trial no
no they won't absolutely not
i would be shocked
shocked
if they did that
have i watched the boys or invincible no
and no
thoughts on american graffiti haven't
seen it in probably 20 years so don't
really have any did i wish did i watch
good omens i've got a review up on the
channel you can find it
uh
let's see
you have to be drunk to get through
jupiter ascending i've heard very mixed
things but anyways i think
yeah it's about time to hit up
the discord yes thank you carowind for
the reminder there it is all right uh
and so this is cut off
no more questions than the discord
so
there are quite a few in there in future
i may have to have the cutoff be the
time at the start
of the
um
stream because i'm going to be on these
for a while
so i think i might have to do that
starting next time
i've noticed stranger things keeps doing
a thing where outcast characters nerds
and queer people assume steve harrington
is going to be an [ __ ] because he's a
rich jock then they're surprised he's a
nice guy what are the duffers trying to
say with that too many people assume
privileged white guys are jerks without
meeting them i get don't judge a book by
its cover it's usually good message but
it seems like a problematic demographic
to associate it with well the thing to
remember is steve was supposed to die in
season one
but the uh the actor they liked him so
much they kept him around and developed
the character into one of my favorite
characters on the show so that's the
first thing to keep in mind so i don't
think they're trying to say anything on
purpose that of course doesn't mean that
they aren't saying things there is some
textual messaging whether you mean it to
me or not
is that a possible takeaway
maybe but the thing is
most of the primary villains are also
influential white guys
you know they are
doctors there's oh god nancy's father's
the biggest freaking tool on the planet
you know
excuse me
um
especially now with season four where
we've got what's his name jason
as a direct counter example no i i don't
feel comfortable
in saying that he becomes a problematic
character because of that
if
if there were fewer counter examples
um
or if
um i felt like that was a more prominent
aspect because i think i think that was
an accidental outcropping of he was just
designed to be
the high school
um
privileged jerk and so people assuming
that he is that actually has more to do
with the reputation he himself earned so
it's less don't judge a book by its
cover than don't assume a person could
never change
because steve did change
he got better but he was that jerk
for a while so people's assumptions
isn't really based off his look so much
as his known history
the u.s showed his true colors
it's worth being clear on this
the um
the
court showed his true colors
because i think something that's very
important
for
both the people within this country
and across the world to remember
the things that are happening now
the
uh weak
ass
gun legislation
the striking down of gun restrictions by
the court the striking down of roe v
wade while there is a vocal minority
within the country that has wanted this
the majority of america
does not want any of this
trump was not elected with a majority of
votes
actually
in the last 20 years
um
or 22 years now only
once
out of the three times that the
conservatives have won only once did
they actually win the popular vote
another two times they took power
regardless
so
this is something i need to remind
myself
because
while there's a lot about this country
that i take a great deal of issue with
i need to remind myself
that most people don't want what's
happening
our system is structured in such a way
that
the right which is a minority holds
absolutely out
um
out of proportion power
and that's what we're dealing with and
that is horrifying but i i have to
remind myself this is not most people
and that doesn't make it any less
dangerous because it's insanely
dangerous however it's important for me
to remember that
um
you know lest i fall into even greater
despair
uh when you read the culture novels by e
m banks does it bother you that banks
uses it for entities that don't have
gender no because pretty much all those
entities are also non-human
um so my problem with using it to
describe a person and i know there are
some people out there who actually like
the pronoun it for themselves so no
judgment on them but barring those
specific instances
my general issue with referring to
people as it is that it is dehumanizing
but if you're going to call an alien
species it well
they
aren't
human
so
you know
would it be better to live in a world
where everyone is born without sex and
gets to pick their biological sex
or stay intersex at puberty all right so
this is another reference to
the culture novels
um
i
think that
a society where that situation
was ingrained as the norm would probably
be healthier
um
it's not something that even if it was
technologically possible would probably
be healthily integrated into the world
as we currently have it require a major
major sea change
in the general perspective of sex and
gender
but
i i would i would expect that a society
with that capability
that made that choice probably has a
healthier
overall relationship with sexuality and
gender uh as a whole as a as a body than
what we have
when talking about uh
abortion rights
should you say women or assigned female
at birth afab uh people
normally i try to default to gender
neutral language but i've heard some
people argue um you should actually say
women in this instance because hatred of
women is what's motivating all this
nonsense in using gender neutral
language to uh
uh works to obscure that somewhat
um
i don't have a firm opinion on that
because i could argue it in either
direction
uh on the one hand like they're not
wrong the
in
the the thing that needs to always be
remembered is that
again while some individuals this may be
true but collectively the anti-abortion
movement is not and has never been about
the safety of
babies it has been about control and it
has been about controlling
the bodies
of women
now
it is also true at the same time that a
decision like the one to overturn roe v
wade
impacts a lot more than only the people
who identify as women and i'm not just
talking about uh signed female at birth
people i'm talking about the fact that
this is actually going to negatively
impact literally
everybody
of all genders
but
that is splash damage that the people
who enacted this do not care about
they don't care that it hurts
transmasculine people they don't care
about the ways in which it will
negatively negatively impact
men who may find themselves roped into
um child support situations that were
suddenly unavoidable or
that
you know they're
uh they are forced to allow for another
um
child to be added to a family that can't
afford to support it or any number of
things the fact that those people also
suffer
is just something that
the anti-abortion groups don't care
about what they care about
is controlling women
and you know especially considering the
fact that
um
you know most of the people who are
anti-abortion aren't gonna have a heck
of a lot of respect for acknowledgement
for
trans masc people anyways
you know
i remember
something like
six 15 16 years ago
when there was a
trans masculine man and a and a couple
who got pregnant
because his wife couldn't
so he carried the baby
it was a feel-good story
it was a feel-good news piece
that is so weird to think about now
but in answer to your question i don't
have a firm answer um i can i can see
the argument being made either way
because it does it does a fact effect
and very directly a lot more than just
those who identify as women but that is
still who the primary target is
ultimately like we're all [ __ ]
with this decision
so
it's it's a it's an argument that i'm
not going to say is unimportant but it's
one that i don't feel strong enough
about to weigh in on definitively
i'm so sick of people judging me for not
being a doomer while i completely
understand it if they have no optimism
and hope for the future then i don't
need them in my life that's fair like i
can
i can be a very cynical very pessimistic
person and actually i'm gonna bring
something up that isn't even like in a
question but i'm gonna bring it up
anyway because i looked into it i found
that so give me a second also i'm not
i'm glad i'm not in red bull's pr team
right now cause they're having idiots
scream at them over one of their drivers
using a racial slur even though it was
purely an understandable pr move some
people just never learn how
lots of people never learn but um i know
in regards to the
the sense of gloom and doom
and the um
just the general atmosphere of of what
are we going to lose next because
uh
a a a certain
justice uh let's call him
terence klamas
um
signaled that he would really love the
court to reconsider
equal marriage rights i.e gay marriage
and the right to contraception
and a bunch of other stuff that he
doesn't like
but
here's something that um
i think
like we should be worried
we should be worried because again they
want these things gone because it gives
them greater control
people who have control and have choices
over their lives who are not part of
this group who are not part of this
conservative
enclave um
they want as many choices and options
stripped from those people as possible
so they can better be controlled
so those things may in fact be
targeted however
strictly speaking legally
those are going to be a lot harder to
reverse
than roe was now keep in mind i'm not a
lawyer
i've never been to law school but this
is what i found looking into this
because i know a lot of people are
panicking
uh about this and not necessarily
wrongful like we should be worried but i
don't think we should be panicking
because
trying to think of the easy way to
explain this so
the measure that was used to overturn
roe uh
is what's called the undue burden
standard and yes i i don't want to get
caught up in the weeds of the fact that
being forced to have a baby is a pretty
friggin undue burden uh but
they made the decision that they made so
we have to move on from that uh at least
in terms of what i'm the point i'm
trying to get to so
that and that is a lower standard
than the strict scrutiny standard that
would have to be applied to trying to
reverse a right to contraception or the
right
of marriage equality basically it has to
do with the legal principles that the
original decisions that granted these
rights were built on
the
legal framework used to decide roe
was a framework that required a lower
level of scrutiny to undo
that
excuse me
i'm so sorry about that then the legal
framework that was used in the decisions
around contraception and marriage
equality
and especially with something like
marriage equality
that is that would be incredibly hard to
undo and actually is true of
contraception as well but like to take
marriage equality for a second part of
the reason for that is
you it is not
allowed under the 14th amendment i
believe to pass a law that is
discriminatory towards a gender and so
part of the basis for marriage equality
was that if you say that these two
people cannot get married because their
genders are the same
that is a law that you have passed that
is discriminatory towards gender so
because that
right is rooted in argument
based directly
into plainly stated language in a
constitutional amendment whereas rho was
a bit more of an extrapolation
um
so a way to think about it is
um it's a
oh it's a wave comparison that i think
people might understand better again
assuming i haven't completely screwed up
explaining this
um think of the comparison between
uh being sued and being criminally
prosecuted so like o.j simpson
he was acquitted of murder because the
standard for a criminal trial is guilty
beyond a reasonable doubt and that is a
much higher standard than the civil
lawsuit where he was sued for their
deaths the deaths of
the two people uh nicole brown simpson
and
i forget the other guy's name but he was
sued for their deaths and he lost in
civil court because in civil court the
burden of proof is much lower it's
basically a preponderance of evidence is
it more likely than not that he is
responsible and the determination was
yes it is more likely than not that he's
responsible therefore he lost in civil
court but he didn't lose in criminal
court because the standard was higher so
that's kind of the comparison to make
so
that some of the other stuff that um
terence clements
uh says he wants to go after
are things that are held to a higher
standard now
that's not bulletproof
because
one of the
really frustrating things about the
courts i've gone off on this for a while
like this was gonna happen forgive me
one of the really frustrating things
about the court
especially in terms of
the scrutiny level that they're supposed
to apply
is that it's kind of an honor system
so
what i just described is in theory
what's supposed to happen in theory
they're supposed to apply
stricter scrutiny
to
um challenges on things
that have the legal the kinds of legal
basis that
marriage equality and the right to
contraception have
however
there really isn't a mechanism in place
to stop them
if more justices are like the
theoretical and completely made-up
terence klamas
and they just
do the thing they want to do regardless
of how much legal scrutiny they are or
aren't supposed to apply and they'll
just claim that they applied that
scrutiny
and just do what they want to do
i don't know if i'm prepared to say that
a majority of justices would actually do
that
uh but
it's an inherent problem with the court
so like
some of what we're dealing with right
now with the court
with the fact that it's a lifetime
appointment it's unelected and the only
way to remove them is they either retire
or they get impeached and only
one supreme court justice has ever been
impeached
and
it's actually even harder to impeach a
justice than to impeach the president
because there's even less laid out in
terms of specifics of what qualifies for
an impeachment
so
the amount of power that the court has
the kinds of things we're dealing with
now and the kind of thing you know i
just talked about saying it's kind of an
honor system we have to take their word
that they're applying the correct amount
of scrutiny
the
the thing is that was always a problem
that's not a new problem
but it's a bit like the um
the electoral college
the problems with the electoral college
have always existed
we just didn't do anything about it
or even think about doing anything about
it
until it stopped working
we just assumed well it's worked okay up
to now it'll probably be fine
which is a very stupid way to proceed
that's the entire way that the
democratic party as a body was treating
the abortion rights well you know yes
they're challenging it yes they're
restricting it but they haven't been
able to get rid of it so far so it'll
probably be fine
[ __ ]
you for an action if there's a problem
if there is something that can go
catastrophically wrong you fix it
before it goes wrong you don't wait for
the damage to happen which is what
happened here
all right i will now actually move on
with the questions
i'm still in the discord i'll try and
speed up through the ones i've got left
uh and over many of your videos you have
multiple different glasses frames uh
prescription frames if so where how do
you get them i'm thinking of getting a
second set of glasses on the cheap in
femme style frames versus
my semi-gender neutral flames with
frames with clip-on glasses zenny
optical z-e-n-n-i i am not sponsored i
would like to be i love their stuff it
is uh quite affordable
uh how would you feel about giving
people the ability the ability to vote
for someone not to win an election like
um
suppose someone really wants trump not
to be president but they also don't
particularly want to vote for biden
uh what if they could go into the booth
and just cast a negative vote for trump
that would cancel out one of his votes
in the final count
that thought came to me earlier when i
was thinking about the fact that a lot
of people disliked biden but didn't want
the gop back in power i kind of wish
there was a way for them to express that
democratically
it's an interesting idea but it has an
inherent flaw in that it makes it much
much much easier for there not
to be a clear majority victor
so like
let's go theoretically
um
if
if we had a system like that in place
and trump lost because of all the
negating votes
but biden but and as a result biden only
had
the support of like
five percent of the population who
actually voted for him in the
affirmative but he wins anyways just
because the other guy was was impacted
so negatively i that doesn't i'm
i think that creates
very similar problems frankly to what
we've already got
uh a positive question
uh
i started using v vera's personal
pronouns for the moment i read greg
again's uh diaspora which is not the
first in that author's famous series of
complex hard sci-fi cyberpunk fiction
from the 90s as being in my 30s makes me
an ancient gay these days i'm 40. shut
up
uh how do we reassure younger folks that
fiction can be a positive escape make
recommendations for them
give them stuff
um that helped you make recommendations
and also understand if they kind of turn
it down because
uh you can't really
uh hold it against people if they're
gonna go stop giving me an escape the
world is still burning and that's where
some people are right now
uh the shirt you're wearing in the
thumbnail how do you actually feel about
less than peaceful uh resistance
uh to this to the statue you ask if you
uh
if you can say while staying uh terms of
service uh okay so in terms of the shirt
here queer and ready to write
there have never been
fundamental rights
um
human rights that had previously been
denied they have never been earned
without
some harsh action
now whether that harsh action
is
throwing a brick at an authority figure
or whether that harsh action
is allowing yourself to be beaten by
police as the world watches
these things are not earned
um
easily
or peacefully
they're not they're just not
and i think in a lot of ways the um
the right to marry
in some ways
in terms of the mentality that it
instilled actually did some serious
damage
because that was the last major victory
um
civil rights victory that
the left kind of had
and it felt like because
like
the original pride movement had you know
started so long ago and it felt like
gays were largely accepted
and that right was generally decided by
it was decided by the court on the
merits of a case
as opposed to
legislation
it felt like it happened without extreme
action
ignoring you know the kind of extreme
action that kicked off gay rights in the
first friggin place
but that's how it felt
and i think it instilled
this thing that obama said
the
i forget exactly what it was but
something like the
the curve of history bends towards
justice
and that's [ __ ]
it's [ __ ]
there is this sense on the left that if
we can just wait them out justice is a
natural
state for the world to enter and it's
not it has to be fought for
however it's possible to fight for it
fight for it in courts and legislations
and if necessary
with heavy objects
that is not
me encouraging
random
acts of vandalism or violence
i am saying however that historically
these things are not
will not
and have never been
given to us
we have to fight for them
and when they try and take them away we
have to fight to keep them
uh one of my favorite books i've read in
last few years is called how
non-violence protects the state
non-violence benefits the status quo
because non-violence while
it can
work
it usually requires very specific
circumstances or it is insanely slow
which
we need change now
do you think your video about the bbc
being privatized will be outdated if as
seems to
uh that seems increasingly likely the
tories finally lose control of the
british government at some point between
now and 2027 i hope it'll be outdated
that would be lovely
i don't have much faith in labor under
cure starmer uh but if they get into
power i would hope they at least stop
the selling off of our government
institutions for a while even if uh
though they should really start
renationalizing stuff if they get in
power well see that's
that's part of the problem with the um
left political parties i'm going to say
that this is less a problem with the
left as a position
and more problem with the left
in terms of the actual party so labor
democrat etc which is that
it has been a very long time
since the left has actually campaigned
on changing anything
generally what they do
is they look at everything that the
conservatives and the right are trying
to strip away from people and going
we're not going to take that from you
i mean like
good
but are you actually going to do
anything
are you going to improve anything are
you going to give us anything more
or are you just going to not actively
hurt us and that's kind of all most of
them have been doing for a while which
is why there's so much disillusionment
on the level well it's one of the
reasons anyways
uh given how freeing cosplay ren fair
play acting is for a lot of queer people
how long before non-essayists um
recognize that uh rent fair goers and
costume nerves are probably better at
costume design modification than people
who only know the other crafts involved
in live theater or theatrical
productions um
i mean kind of depends on
where you go uh there's certainly a lot
of like if you get into the local level
with things like community theater
you'll probably find some overlap uh in
some places between
uh rent fair goers and like community
theater costumers and things like that
but you know it's just a question of how
accepted the nerds are i suppose
uh what would you say to someone who
thinks is too dangerous to hold public
pride events because they create easy
targets for right wing mass
shooters carry a brick
that is the point of terrorism which
let's be very clear
anyone on the right
trying to connect trying to enact
violence on the left
is committing terrorism because their
intent is to put a population in a state
of fear
and the strongest way to have that not
win
is to not let them drive us underground
more than a desire to actually shoot us
up they want to not ever have to look at
us again
there's only so many elements on the
right that actually want queer people
dead
there are some
there are absolutely some
but most of the right just wants us back
in the closet they don't ever want to
see us again
they don't want us on the street they
don't want us to be publicly proud
we are at a point
it's funny
probably about 12 years ago
i wrote a blog which is not up online
anymore
but i wrote a blog
questioning whether
pride was still
helpful
in terms of
its purpose as protest because that was
a point in time and i was also young
enough and experienced enough to think
that boy it sure seems like people
accept
queer people just fine as is
are we coming off as abrasive
that's a position that i very strongly
no longer hold
because we are absolutely unquestionably
at a point in time again where us simply
being out and
present and public that is already a
form of protest that is us saying we
will not
go back into the god damn closet
and
i won't be pushed there
and i don't
anyone who feels personally unsafe
you are not obligated to go out to these
events
however
these events have become once more
the acts of defiance that they
originally started as
because they are trying to make us
disappear
and public pride events is us saying we
will not
i've seen lots of people getting mad
that the democrat at the democrats for
not codifying roe v wade into law during
the times they were empowered i don't
want to argue the democrats aren't kind
of useless but when people say that are
they failing to understand that until
very recently
bring being pro-life wasn't viewed as an
exclusively far-right position like uh
the democrats have had a super majority
twice since or when both times it was
only with pro-life democrats getting
them over the line
um
i do think
people fail to take that into
consideration but the thing is
even the pro-choice democrats especially
when you get to the senate you get a few
more fire brands in the house like your
aocs
um but once you get to the senate they
are so
so middle of the road and so milk toast
and just so nothing
yeah i uh
i deal with the democrats because
they're what i'm stuck with i don't have
a lot of use for them though
you'd love trey crowder oh that that was
liberal redneck on youtube wasn't he i
think he was good i liked him i haven't
checked out his stuff in a while
all right i'm getting towards the end of
these more people posted more stuff i
did say i wasn't going to address stuff
that was put in the discord after i
started answering these questions so i'm
really sorry i'm really sorry if it's
something you really desperately want me
to address
you can try putting it in the general
chat once i'm back to the main chat
window or do it as a super chat but i
said i was gonna have a cutoff and i'm
gonna and next time next time i'm
putting in the rule that questions have
to be submitted before the stream starts
because this is taking up a lot more
time than it used to
uh what's wrong with light year's
premise i watched toy story as a kid i
did kind of wonder where buzz believed
he was from i mean like as someone who
didn't watch um toy story as a kid i
just don't understand the instinct to
take a character a beloved character and
completely remove them from the context
in which they were beloved and also give
them a completely different personality
and voice
at that point it's not even just
transporting the character to a
different setting it's a different
character
so what what what's the point
i don't get it
ryan gosling's bootleg shooty got to a
doctor
uh who shirt thing was crazy that i have
not seen him i have to check that
i've recently binged all of season one
of arcane and was wondering if you had a
favorite character from it
um
it might be silko
he's a really good villain
he's really good i like him a lot
um but they're all
such a good cast of characters in that
with this is the last one then i'm back
in the main chat with regard to the
umbrella academy should an actor's own
gender identity or sexuality inform how
you write the characters they play like
if you played a character uh do you have
the right to expect them to reflect your
own queer or straight status okay so i'm
gonna talk i'm gonna answer that in two
ways one to the specifics of the
umbrella academy and two uh broadly
speaking
so with the specifics of the umbrella
academy elliot page was willing to come
back and continue to play the character
as he had played uh
her previously
it was actually the showrunner who was
like i want to change this to
accommodate you
so this was um
this was kind of done in conjunction it
was something that the creator kind of
wanted to do for him
uh which i think was was very nice and
the interesting side effect of that
is because the scripts had already been
written when elliott came out
the changes were just little bits of
dialogue here and there they didn't have
the time to rewrite the scripts and make
it a more
deeply rooted integrated part of the
story and i actually think it's better
for it so we kind of got a happy
accident with that one
now
broadly speaking that really is a
case-by-case basis and it's going to
depend on the actor in question um
because some actors
will be comfortable
playing something that does not match
their gender identity or maybe even
matches an identity that they
transitioned out of so like i did voice
work for um dominic martin for a um
doctor who fan audio last year
and i played a cisgender male character
and i was fine to do that i didn't have
any discomfort to do that and i'd be
happy to do voice work at least as a cis
male character again
um
so
a big part like it's one it's one of the
things you have to be careful about
making assumptions about because i it
comes up when when the conversation
about should uh you know with
queer people playing queer characters
and you shouldn't have straight cis
people playing queer characters
etc one of the things
that is so frequently assumed by people
who push back on some of these
principles is that
well you know
uh
what if there are some scenes prior to
the transition well the the actor is
going to have dysphoria you don't know
that
some will yes but not all
different actors have different comfort
levels and that should theoretically be
taken into account when they are
auditioning or putting themselves
forward or being asked to play any given
part
um
so i
stick to my general principle that i
want to see queer people playing queer
characters ideally ones that match their
own identity
if an actor is willing and has no issue
playing a cis straight character you're
not obligated to change it to match that
if you make the decision that you want
to because you think they'll be able to
play it even better if it matches their
identity that's fine too
but as long as the actor is comfortable
with however it is that it's been
scripted
i'm fine
as far as that goes
and yes to reiterate i am okay with
queer people playing cisgender um
and heterosexual characters i am not
okay with cis people playing trans
characters especially or uh
sister-straight people playing queer
characters in general i'm a little bit
softer on straight people playing gay
characters yeah i don't love it but cis
people playing trans people not okay
it's super not okay it's actually really
damaging right now so
some people call that hitter
hypocritical i've done multiple videos
on it so i won't cover it again here
all right
apologies to the people who posted more
questions in there i told you i wasn't
gonna
i wasn't gonna come back so all right
i've got super chats to catch up to hang
on let me do these
john vinyls thank you very much for the
super chat stranger things hot take the
soviet union
soviet union was bad the cia also sucks
how un-american of you say the c.i.a
sucks
supreme omega thank you for the super
chat uh would a more socialist democracy
be more ideal
in my mind it would be would it be
perfect no because humans are imperfect
creatures and we will never come up with
a perfect system
but um i think what we've got right now
is fundamentally broken in a
lot of ways
and
um
democratic socialism
i certainly agree with a lot more of the
principles of democratic socialism than
i do with whatever the hell it is that
we have going on here
uh tiki dragon one thank you so much the
people should vote for justices
otherwise we get crap like this
i'm not necessarily sure i
so
i'm not sure i necessarily agree because
there are other
lower judges can be elected and that
actually causes its own problems
because
okay so i'm going to say something that
i'm going to have to explain what i mean
having judges be elected injects
politics into the court now politics
already do exist in the court to the
extent that they are political
appointees um and obviously they have
their own political opinions but what i
mean is
the idea that a judge has to
um
court voters
and the ways they might do that if we
look at what goes on in lower court
elections as a template no that would be
a nightmare i do think the lifetime
appointment thing is a bad idea
i think if they're going to maintain a
lifetime appointment
it should either be easier to remove
them or
better just get rid of that i think we i
think it should be
i don't know i'll pick a number
uh 20-year term
let's go with that
20 years if they live if they live to
see the end of that
and then somebody else comes in
um
my bigger issue is with lifetime
appointment now lifetime appointment
combined with unelected that is a twofer
but if we could get rid of the lifetime
appointment part of it i would have less
issue
um oh head kittens thank you for the
heart and the super chat i greatly
appreciate that
and lord cyber ram
vera i'm okay to identify as the doctor
i'll thank you for the super chat doctor
okay i'm now actually caught up and i'm
actually looking at the chat
itself
finally
20 years would work better than lifetime
yeah lifetime appointments in general
just
aren't a good idea
like they're deeply inherently
undemocratic by their nature like
king is a lifetime appointment what the
hell are we doing with having lifetime
appointments supreme court should follow
the uk example uh where they serve till
75 and have to be politically neutral
well i mean theoretically they're
supposed to be politically neutral here
as well
um
they're not because no human being is
politically neutral but
in theory they are meant to apply the
law but they still have to have
their own personal framework with how to
apply it so like to take the
um
the late and not missed antonin scalia
he was an originalist
he believed that what mattered was the
original intention
by the founding fathers
and that any extrapolations
of that
um saying well they said this and we're
going to take that to mean all these
other things he would say no it just
says this
so from his perspective
basically anything that couldn't be
traced to pretty much word for word uh
foundation in the constitution he had no
use for now that was his
judicial framework that he came with
the result of that was that he aligned
super
um big time with uh
with conservative
ideals values and positions
because even if i think he was just a
conservative in general but even if he
wasn't and that was just his judicial
framework it still put him in a
political context and a political
perspective so the idea of a politically
neutral court is
frankly kind of naive now you certainly
don't want a blatantly political court
where they're just like
you're a democrat so i'm going to rule
against you like that
but you know
that shouldn't be the standard by which
we job we judge
what's too far
but you know
politics exists in the court system
whether we like it or not
and pretending it's what it's one of
those things like
it's a fine thing to aim for that to not
be the case
um
but it will always be the case and we
better accept that
i haven't seen arcane mainly because of
two things one is the fan base and how
toxic they can be oh i actually have not
engaged with the fan base of arcane at
all so i can't speak to that
and two i personally think the animation
looks ugly i get uh that style it's not
for me oh that's a shame if you don't
like the visual style give it a pass i
think the visual style is gorgeous
in that show personally
but yeah if you don't like it but it is
meant to be a visual
production i mean like it's a visual
medium all things are um in in tv and
streaming but
my point is
you know they put a lot of effort into
those visuals and if those visuals
aren't playing for you aren't working
for you it's
it's a bit like not liking the
performance of a lead actor
that's kind of a reason not to do it
do i like energy drinks no not really i
identify as mystique
i heard you can imitate them perfectly
even their voice
even their voice
so why don't you
pretend all the time you know
looked like them
because we shouldn't have to
court justices should not be politically
appointed it's shocking
the us does this as most countries have
judiciary and government as independent
yeah our appointment system isn't great
um
the problem is at this point uh the
the work that would have to
be done to
um
disentangle those things and make the
judiciary not even politically appointed
um
it's it's bigger change than is gonna
happen certainly in my lifetime if there
was even an appetite for them there
doesn't seem to be
uh
oh hey john hey jbl it's good to see you
uh love the behind the scenes vid of the
recording room was wondering where the
stuffed bibo was i missed him he's not
down here
uh
bibo's in my bedroom
with the stuff he's on my bed
uh that's where bibo lives so
you can thank kay for me again for that
uh
rusty ralston thank you chibnall
uh did right kiss kiss gang bang bang oh
okay so that's the best torchwood thing
he ever wrote then
um thank you for confirming that for me
supreme omega once again thank you on
tram's rep do you feel the game of you
arc uh with the character wanda and
gaiman's sandman age well or is it too
dated even with good intentions
i think
it was quite good for the time
including some things that
he admits he got right by accident
so like
minor spoiler
the there's a trans character in the
sandman comics who dies and
one of the characters later goes to her
funeral
and
it's noted that
her
mother who didn't accept her
had her prepared
you know for the funeral viewing
um
masculine had her hair cut
no makeup
and this person who went to go
you know to this funeral who knew her as
she really was
um really saw the tragedy in this and
gaiman didn't realize that was the thing
that actually happened
he wrote it because
that's where his
um
narrative and dramatic instincts as a
writer took him
and he happened to hit upon a pretty
strong truth
doing that
i haven't reread game of you in a while
i suspect that if i ever do i'm going to
find
some things to take issue with
but
certainly for the time
it was quite good
i suspect that it's probably aged
decently
but i suspect if i were to reread it now
i would spot the ways in which oh this
was
written by
uh a cisgender straight guy a
well-meaning one um
but i haven't actually reread it in a
while so i couldn't say one way or the
other
wasn't scalia catholic
one of the founding fathers think of
catholics again oh don't get me started
on that i always love when they talk
about the founding fathers they all what
would the founding fathers want well you
know at least one of them
said flat out that we should throw out
the constitution and rewrite the entire
thing every 20 years or so
just saying
at council of geeks curse your long name
for stealing the vast majority of my
allowed 200 characters
i make no apologies
uh
have i seen the hocus pocus 2 teaser i
did
it's at i don't care
that's kind of it
how do you feel about arcane in the
context of it being uh an ad for riot
games who are not good i don't love the
association um
i will say though
that
nothing about that show made me want to
play the game especially when i found
out how the game works i'm like the game
is one of those games where like the
story is all lore you're not actually
playing an active story and so
i'm not sure how good an ad
for the games it actually is
since the games
aren't very story driven
not like an actual story unfolding
so
i don't love the association is there
but i deal with it
let's see what are my thoughts on the
princess bride it's a classic for a
reason
uh does bibo live with britney now no
no
[Laughter]
no go sir
britney is not on the bed with the
stuffies
oh
oh ye gods
uh
when i say that i have problems with the
fan b base of arcane i'm talking about
the league of legends fandom because
arcane is based on uses character and
lore from it ah okay that makes more
sense because most video game fandoms
are super toxic which is why i don't
engage in video game fandoms
it's a crime um they never gave mystique
claremont's original story for a
nightcrawler's origin i know
i know for people who don't know what
chris claremont wanted to do
because misty because of mystique's
shape-shifting powers
um
he wanted mystique to be
not nightcrawler's mother as she was
eventually revealed to be but to be
nightcrawlers
father
had with
mystique's
female love interest
destiny
i'm still bitter they didn't let him do
that i'm not surprised
given that this was what the 80s
um but i'm better
would you like me to impose a five limit
question on myself in regards to the
discord i do that in other contexts
where it puts creators in an awkward
position because i have so many um if
you're willing 255 a.d uh actually i
would appreciate it
um
if you're willing to do that yeah that
actually that that would be helpful
if people in your bedroom just like nate
bieber loves you oh hey jesse look at
you sneaking in and i got gurgley there
that got like gremlin ass hold on
billboard
loves you
people want cuddles
almost done we're almost there
yeah i love and hate that storyline and
sandman yeah again i i suspect if i were
to reread it i'd be like oh this bit's
good but
it's been a while though
i reread game of you last year it holds
up decently for the most part but for
the time it was great yeah that's that's
about what i expect
thoughts on adrift it was the torchwood
episode where uh the people were going
missing and jack was keeping them in an
island because they've gone insane it's
one of my favorite chibnalls um
it's that one with jack's brother i
remember hating that
like that aspect
i hate secret siblings
they're almost never good
uh
let's see where was i
i don't really remember adrift very well
if i'm being honest
bieber loves britney oh god no
no
jbl no
don't ah don't do that
uh
uh vera while you're on discord was
requested you amplified the need to
delete period trackers yes
any apps that you use to help you
monitor your reproductive health
you need to delete them immediately
because in areas where
abortion is criminalized to the point
that prosecutors have the
freedom to prosecute not only the
doctors performing the
um procedures but on the people who have
them
have those procedures
the data from those tracking apps can be
subpoenaed and used in court as evidence
delete them
immediately
what are my thoughts on the casper movie
it's just kind of dumb
i've been watching in ages
my oldest plays league of legends says
it's a very fun but toxic fun game with
toxic fan base i mean
this is why i don't play competitive
multiplayer
they get that way very very quickly
i'm sorry remember cats you do now
how am i i'm okay all things together do
you know the lyrics to wear the
spaceballs ah i used to i don't anymore
uh loki and mystique walk into a bar
i dig it
ah
oh and john finals thank you i hope for
the super chat
um
let me see
um did you know there's a comic relief
special where the 11th doctor straight
up says he had sex with a nun
i think i missed that one
if i saw it i don't remember it
no it's not the one with jack's brother
okay all right i think i did like it
then
i
i
a lot of torchwood has
blurred together and what sticks out is
unfortunately mostly the bad stuff
uh strum dynasty
hello there i would love to see a video
with you tearing down the disney
quote-unquote groomer nonsense more it
persists uh and you tend to do a good
job addressing this crap
yeah we're at a point where
the word groomer is almost useless
trying to use it for its actual original
intended meaning because of the way it
is being
deployed as a political weapon at this
point
um
especially just against not only
queer people but their allies
and
i don't have the spoons right now
to dig into that uh topic any more than
i already have
i'm i i am glad that um
that uh you think i've done good in
addressing this kind of thing but
it's a it's a topic worth addressing
and i might but
at least in the immediate future i i i
don't have the spoons
i was wondering if someone was going to
have to explain in the chat what what
the deal with britney was
that's it
now that we know bibo loves brittany oh
that explains the purple goo oh no
ah
knitting crochet tiger ah how dare you
uh
giving them a heartbear yes uh
thank you for that um
lewis ward
engaged mutual blinking
wish a new morse code could have made a
joke out of that
uh
let's see
you can be compelled by police to unlock
phone with biometrics but cannot be
propelled to
provide passcodes stay safe at all yes
that is also true um
so if you normally have it up with
have it set up with face recognition or
fingerprint scan what you do um
if you are saying being pulled over by
the police or stopped uh turn your phone
off like shut it down because when you
restart it it's going to require the
passcode and to uh to basically start up
the biometric options again
or you can just disable those as
unlocking tactics
have i been backpacking before over
multiple days no just day hikes
mystique as nightcrawler's father well
my childhood is now in shambles thanks
vera
kidding i'm not against that being in
the movies just so it'll take some
getting used to
unfortunately logan it's not canon
wish it was but it's not
all right i am gonna wrap it up you know
what we're close enough to nine we'll
wrap it up on the hour
can we see your archery title you won
over the weekend
you've been practicing by piercing all
our hearts um well what i want you can't
unfortunately because what i won
was a short bow that i gave to liz
because i still have the longbow that i
won from the last time i won that
tournament
so
um my sign of victory is currently in
the possession of my partner so that we
are now both armed
leave brittany alone
but sheeps and pets need to be groomed
oh god
yeah
head cannon is better than cannon often
often it can be
lewis ward thank you very much
i eat i'm off to bed but remember you're
beautiful you're valid
you're loved we may be the council but
you're the reason we come to the channel
thank you
ah
thank you for that
vera as hawkeye
i'm not that good but apparently i'm
quite quite good by the local standards
do i practice archery regularly no
no i don't have a space to do it first
of all i need to get the longbow uh
restrung and i actually do have a target
um but
my yard's not big enough well i'll
revise that my yard is big enough in
terms of
i do have enough space but like
it's it would still be unsafe because i
have enough space to put a proper amount
of distance
between
the target and myself
however
what i'm lacking is a safe place for air
for wild arrows to go
so there's nowhere that i can put the
target that wouldn't result in a
wild arrow either
hitting the house
or
flying into somebody else's yard so
that's the problem it's less that my
yard isn't big enough and in that i have
neighbors
so no i don't practice regularly i i
picked up archery from the day camp i
went to
um
when i was in grade school i i would go
to a day camp near my grandparents and
they had archery and that's where i got
into it
but
no i don't practice regularly
which
i would like to that to me basically
says to me
i could be better than i am
and i'm already two for two at winning
archery tournaments at the local rent
fair so
i could be even better
did hold on
the couple that fledges together stays
together
uh have you ever listened to doctor who
fan audios um
only a couple
not a ton like i haven't even had time
to listen all the big finish that i own
uh much less listen to all the fan
audios um i did a review of one i
actually got commissioned to do do a
review of one um just
last month
i think
um in the break room of geeks and
obviously i was in one and i listened to
the other ones that um
that dominic martin who chaser produced
i'd recommend those
but i don't have um i haven't listened
to that many
um can they even be well written or deep
enough to
trigger me though but just make me doubt
them see the thing is
if you can
find
good performers
you don't need a big budget to do decent
audio
you need some know-how
um you know to do proper audio
editing
but
raw cost
um
if
everybody's contributing their time
i.e you're not paying the actors
you can do a lot
did the overturner also kill a big
privacy protection law i'm not
that i know of it has
it has
created a situation where privacy
protection now appears very vulnerable
to future challenges
um
but i don't
believe
that the decision in and of itself
um
overturned that
our dream private yards is illegal where
i live which it probably should be
it sounds like you need to join a
shooting club or take your boat to their
range i gotta find out what there is
around here because
i suspect most um
archery ranges would be at
things that are also gun ranges and i
don't really want to
be around guns i don't know i haven't
looked into it i need to
most toxic fandom of all time no idea
it's an ongoing competition there will
never be a victor we all lose
last question from me have you
considered checking out other reviews
before posting your own because you
might miss something because you didn't
pick up on it or some such you know uh
no
no because in my mind
um
if i miss something
then
if people want to say that's on me
that's fine i'll own that if i put a
review and people point out but you
completely missed blah
i'm prepared to own up to that my ego is
not so fragile that i can't deal with
that
and i don't like
i always worry about my opinions being
shaped and tainted by
other peoples or or failing that that my
review will become a response to
somebody else's review as opposed to a
review of the thing itself
so no i never check out other reviews
not on purpose anyways it happens by
default whenever i watch like older
stuff i may have encountered reviews or
be aware of the general reception but
like for stuff that just came out like
new episodes of doctor who etc no i
never look at other people's reactions
before shooting mine ever ever ever
could we recommend the woman under the
roof
yes
yes you can recommend one woman under
the roof
woman onto the roof is a really good
very interesting doctor who fan audio
that's also a tough listen but for good
reasons
but it is a bit of a tough listen
wolf 359 is podcast that i think does
really well in audio format despite very
limited resources like bad audio quality
and limited cast related to the audio
thing like if you know how to work
within your limitations you'd be
surprised what can happen
excuse me
i would go shooting arrows with you i
can look into areas around both of us to
see if there's a non-shooting rage
option
i'll be there
like we need to hang out in general we
haven't seen each other in freaking ages
but yeah
did i have a sweet tooth as a kid no
more than usual i don't think
kenobi my review for the last episode is
up and it has my thoughts on the thing
as a whole
are you watching following the new
season of the boys i haven't watched the
boys
i don't like garth ennis
and i i've i've heard people say that
like it's better than his writing tends
to be or at least by the second season
it is but
i just don't like the work of the guy
who wrote the original piece
and at this point now it's three seasons
in i'm like i've just got other stuff
i'd rather watch
i was joking i wrote the story i know
that you didn't have to tell them
i knew that
i was in on it with you
if you lived in zootopia what kind of
animal would you be squirrel
i'm sure you don't watch strange new
worlds i don't but there's a trans femme
envy character in one episode
and she's awesome can't be sexy villain
i've heard very good things about
strange new worlds i might
zero promises
i might
check that one out
simply because
it's a brand new show so i don't have to
go back and catch them on multiple
seasons
no promises but that's a maybe
best chip no who meme
you're doing it mate benny or evil dan
i i don't know i kind of like you do it
in my
i don't know i kind of like that one
i was kidding about the woman under the
roof thing but thank you for answering
though
no it was a good piece
it was really well done was really well
performed and i know that because it was
hard to listen to
because with the material it was
tackling it should have been and it was
five minutes thank you carowind for the
warning
uh welp i'm dumb for today see you next
time remember no matter what
anyone may say you were loved and screw
carl dennis
um
adhd squad here we'd all be squirrels
yeah
yeah pretty much
strange new world is mo's favorite star
trek now we watch it every week
uh we can zoom you in it is so amazing
um i i have a means to see it
but i i would have to back up and
like again i'm just
ah i've got i've got like
i've got three things
that i really need to get done
before i start sinking into
you know something that would eat up a
decent amount of time
and i really gotta start getting that
stuff done
these were actual lyrics magneto's
hordes are on the way to pillage burn
and plunder
but there's one hero that's here to stay
the team that strikes with thunder ah
lord
that's
uh
let's see
your favorite character in arcane is
victor
victor like they're they're all good
there really isn't a bad character in
that show
which video do i regret making the most
i'm not sure i regret making anything
um
[Music]
the closest i come to regret
um
is maybe the inside number nine videos
not because i have any regret about
anything i said about it but because of
the hatred of a fandom that i didn't
realize was full of [ __ ] descending
on me because i had a couple of
criticisms here and there
um
i regret stepping into that not knowing
i was what i was getting into that's
what i regret i don't regret what i s
what i said i don't even really regret
watching the show
although that fandom did put me off
after watching it anymore but
dog person or cat person i like dogs a
little better i do like cats though i
like both
i think grievo will get a spin-off um
she's clearly been positioned to be able
to have one i don't know though it's a
tough call
we're about to wrap up
so we've got another super chat
any more super chats coming in this is
your chance we are wrapping up very very
soon
constantly currently gonna blast the
song hope the country song from estonia
all night long good night
whatev whatever gets you through
rusty absolutely
imagine a new show ruining your
childhood the privilege like i oh
just that whole idea
is
your head's gotta be so far up your own
ass
thoughts on chris pratt he's acting in
his celebrity image
his acting is
fine in the right place
he can either be
grating or endearing depending on the
framing of the character he's endearing
guardians of the galaxy he's grading in
la and uh jurassic world and it's
effectively the same damn character
a lot of it has to do with framing he's
he's pretty limited as an actor that
does and that's not the same as being a
bad actor he's decent at what he does
but what he does is pretty limited
as far as his celebrity image
i've not gotten on the chris pratt uh
hate train
largely because
honestly
the connections being made between him
and the
anti-queer church
that he was supposedly affiliated with
are kind of shaky and thin and always
have been and the degree of certainty
that people
speak about well he believes this and i
look into it i'm like
yeah maybe
but you speak with such authority that
you're certain that he thinks x
and i can't find it
so honestly his p his public image makes
me uncomfortable not because of him but
because of how
dead certain some people are about what
they think
he does or doesn't think
i've started showing insight number nine
to my new uh support worker
so i i have rewatched that episode
hope you had fun i hope you have more
fun than i did too many disney plus
shows too many of all shows
there's it's all too much
am i non-binary or female i am gender
fluid
which is a non-binary identity i do
consider myself to be trans femme
um
i'm not a woman nor am i a trans woman
trans femme meaning that my transition
has brought me into a more feminine
space my general sense of self is more
feminine leaning um although i do still
have more sort of neutral gender-neutral
days um i don't really have much of a
connection to my masculinity anymore but
i i consider myself genderfluid that is
a non-binary identity it is also a trans
identity but i am not a trans woman
oh
chris pad is mostly tool it seems our
greatest
essay on how he represents the military
industrial complex
on how he does or how the characters he
plays do because that
there is a difference
like you can decide whether or not that
difference is splitting hairs but
there is a difference
okay that's it
last two grapes oh
and we're done
ran this for um
for an hour longer than
originally planned
so
let's wrap it up thank you everybody for
joining me we did cover some heavy stuff
but i think we also got to have some fun
which
i'm really appreciative for
twitch thank you carowind
twitch tomorrow
at 10 30
uh a.m eastern
uh i will be i'm gonna get back into
pyre i think
so i'll resume playing pyre
um
and i'll definitely play that this week
i might play some i might start playing
pyre on my own time and switch to
something else next week
steam had a massive sale so i've now got
like a bunch of games
uh to to try out
so
next week i might do something else but
this week it's gonna be pyre
um so you can join me on twitch for that
also tomorrow and the break room of
geeks
um there will be
um
my review of
actually what will be the latest episode
of ms marvel and the one from last week
because i was on vacation
and didn't talk about that but
that
should
cover it i think for the immediately
coming up stuff uh saturday's video
is going to be on
um how trauma
is currently being used to inform
villainy
uh as a trope in
storytelling
so uh that'll be that'll be saturday i
shot that today gotta edit that
and i think that should have about
covered it and usual stuff twitter tik
tok instagram
blah blah blah blah bl
so
thank you everybody
thank you for tuning in
please remember that you are beautiful
you are valid
you are loved
you are the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
mccavity